est ce que tu es lâcher prise je vous
dis que je sais ce qui m'attend je vais
brûler la dernière fois que je vous ai
vu théâtre c'était il ya près de neuf
ans au théâtre du nouveau monde dans la
pièce le huis clos de jean-paul ça ouais
a longtemps dopé
et là vous revenez au théâtre neuf
amputant quoi la grande question oui que
je me posais moi-même maintenant ici
c'est pourquoi j'ai attendu si longtemps
ben y'a plein de concours de
circonstances j'ai eu des enfants qui
sont des adolescents maintenant que je
peux laisser le soir à la maison sans
problème par parce que j'ai beaucoup
tourné parce que j'ai fêté syrie après
que le numéro un on a dit jamais pour
faire une clémence mais c'est pas une
bonne raison
pars pars pour être très honnête
peut-être de la scène - parfois mais
pourtant le clou statut tout seul
oui oui c'est tout succès et est une
épreuve pour moi parce que je suis pas
habitué à la semaine c'est pas un espace
abonnement familier pour moi parce que
je viens du cinéma j'ai beaucoup dit
j'ai grandi là dedans j'ai pas fait
d'école de théâtre j'ai pas parce que
j'ai pas de démystifier s'était pas cet
espace le scénic aujourd'hui sur le
second à 50 ans j'ai peut-être pour ça
que j'ai rien à terme et que j'ai envie
j'ai envie de le prendre ce risque là
j'ai envie j'ai envie de ce danger leur
je trouve que ce n'est ce pas extrêmes
le terrain votre grand retour au théâtre
ce sera dans l'assemblée présenté ici à
l'espace go de quoi ça va parler
exactement l'assemblée c'est un théâtre
documentaire donc la démarche est de se
coller le plus de plus possible une
réalité dont quatre femmes qui ont été
rassemblés il ya quelques mois au mois
de mai je crois pour discuter de
certains enjeux de société au québec
notamment l'immigration la condition des
femmes leur posture l'opposition
politique
c'est un défi assez grand parce que
c'est franchement des positions voire
presque opposés et qui sont et qui
peuvent être le reflet de ce qu'on vit
dans notre société et puis que c'est je
pense que les gens de gauche vont se
targuer d'être extrêmement incluse
effectué est extrêmement ouvert sur
l'immigration mais quand on adresse la
vraie question du port du voile
ça peut être très confrontant n'en finit
plus je me dis que tu dois te rrain
enfants j'ai dit que moi j'ai un enfant
je voulais lui tout seul ce que vous
avez toujours jouer des rôles de femme
émancipée des femmes fort les wiiware
ouais ça vous rejoins ce genre de
personnage entendez vous les tiki tube
ce que je dégage ça dans la vie même si
je suis limité c'est comme le grand
paradoxe mais je pense que j'étais une
femme émancipée lui une femme de mon
temps je me forme ou est complètement
mais c'est pas si simple que ce que je
veux dire c'est pas si simple que si on
peut avoir un discours on peut on peut
accomplir des choses dans notre
existence aux nouveaux professionnels
qui donnent l'impression que on est
affranchi bon tu rentre tout de suite le
rester en dessous du pic la semaine
c'est clair mais
dans l'intimité dans leurs rapports avec
la nature il ya beaucoup de choses de
chemin à faire en corse etc
c'est très complexe justement quelle est
la solution parce que j'ai lu quelque
part que vous avez en quelque sorte mis
de côté votre carrière en europe pour
vous occuper de vos enfants
j'étais devenue comédienne avoue
retrouver lors de mes enfants s'est
beaucoup occupé de mes enfants pour me
laisser donner la chance d'aller tourner
les films un peu partout le tissu est
quand même tourner des films en europe
il est nul phare quand même du phare
avec grand plaisir la liste est pauvre
comme une espèce d'obligation bien sacré
c'est un sacrifice yale c'est comme ça
que j'étais très très chanceuse de
pouvoir vivre ça même si ça n'a pas été
j'ai pas plus populeux exclure dans tout
ce que ce trajet la culpabilité que j'ai
ressenti comme maire
face à ces éloignements sporadiques le
type et ça tombait souvent qu'au mois de
septembre octobre et les tournages de la
rentrée brèche pour le polar et c'est
épouvantable pour une mère de six
enfants dans l'autobus de pouvoir partir
donc oui ça c'est quelque chose d'un peu
déchirant un là dedans mais bon à mon
dieu comment dire c'est peut-être le
prix d'une certaine liberté
je pense que les enfants mangent oeil
aujourd'hui c'est des bons garçons j'ai
eu la chance d'avoir une carrière
vraiment qui me permit de m'affranchir
de beaucoup de choses
ceci n'aurait pas eu cette carrière là
cette exposition le je pense que j'en
serai là aujourd'hui comme ça
franchement c'est quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup beaucoup aidé m
ce qui m'a donné beaucoup de force merci
beaucoup merci merci